- Alright, what's up, guys. I'm Nasher here joined
alongside Trevor Zegras from the Anaheim Ducks.
It's been a crazy week for you.
I want to get down to the beginning, right?
You starting as a hockey player, have you always been
kind of that creative player? Like, were there any guys
in the league that you were looking up to?
Pavel Datsyuk, any guys like that?
- Yeah, I mean, I was a big Kaner fan.
- OK
- When I was younger, I love I love the way he played.
Obviously, Datsyuk, Crosby, I think all those guys,
I mean, I think it just just in general, I think I was
just a hockey fan, so I loved watching everybody.
But I definitely say Kaner was probably my favorite
player growing up and all the crazy passes and spin
moves that he did. I mean, I loved trying that in the
driveway or minor hockey or at prep school and all
that good stuff.
- So I want to talk about the play that happened with you
and Sonny Milano.
Obviously, you took the hockey world by storm.
Walk me through that play step-by-step.
So you're sitting behind the net.
Milano calls out for the "Michigan".
What's going through your head?
- Yeah. Well, I mean, at first I tried to kind of just
tried to settle the puck down and see if anybody would
kind of chase me behind the net. And once my guy, I
guess it was the right side for me, kind of just decided
to chill out on the post.
Obviously, Sony was calling for the "Michigan", and I
knew I couldn't couldn't do the actual "Michigan" because
that guy was kind of chillin' on the post.
So I just flipped it over the net and he was ready for
it and he made a great play.
So I mean, I feel like most of the credit should be going
to him because without Sonny, I mean, that's just
a just a it's a it's a no play, really.
And for him to kind of put it in that top corner,
was was definitely pretty special on his end.
- So this is not something that you guys had like, worked
on practice the night before?
The flip play? Obviously, you're working on that
"Michigan" and lacrossing it all day, but the flip play
was not something you drew up, right?
- No, we never even talked about that before.
- Wow
- That's why I was pretty shocked when it went in, I didn't
really know what happened, because the guy kind of pushed
me after I flipped it over the net, so I didn't really
see it. So I was kind of just in shock like did we really
just do that?
- Dude, that's unreal. I think that makes the play even
better. Do you have a target on your back when you're
behind the net? Like, do you feel like the opponents kind
of know that these crazy things are coming?
Do you feel like they want to maybe hit you harder
because of that or anything?
- I don't know. But it was- the next game, we we were in
Columbus and we played Columbus, and I got behind the net
in the first period and I got two guys kind of just came
right on me and pinned me up the boards so I was like
maybe that's maybe that's the end of my run behind the net.
- So let's talk about some of your other plays too,
right? You try to go between your legs, didn't go in, you
go back to the bench. You're a little bummed out.
Are your your teammates a little rattled by that?
Or they want you to go with a simple backhand?
Like, what's that like?
- No, they think it's awesome.
For the most part. Nobody really kind of gets on me for
doing that stuff. I don't know, like a lot of people
like, they love to like comment or chime in to say like
he gotta just go backhand there.
But like to me, like, I just don't understand.
Like, what's the difference between like flipping a
backhand versus like flipping a forehand?
And I think, honestly, I looked at it a couple of times,
and I think it was just a a great save by, I think it was
Robin Lehner on Vegas.
He read it great. And he kind of stayed with me.
But I thought, I guess I had enough speed that he kinda
be following the puck and it would kind of just sneak
in, I guess, on the far side, but he made a great save.
- You're the definition of changing the game, right,
people have to change the way that they play and you're
making them do that. And speaking of changing the game,
we couldn't have this talk without bringing this up.
John Tortorella, his comments on you.
I'm sure you saw them.
What are your thoughts on what he had to say?
- Yeah. I mean, I thought it was definitely a little out
of the ordinary because, weird, I always liked
Torts, man. Like growing up, I was a big Ranger fan.
Obviously, he coached the Rangers, so I was always
a big Tortorella fan. I love kind of that he was a little
bit outspoken and had his own opinion, and Sonny,
Sonny played for him for five years and Sonny had nothing
but great things to say about him.
So I guess for him to kind of take
that goal. I don't know if he took it personal or
whatnot, but it's definitely, definitely
a little out of the ordinary, for sure.
And I guess, like you said, I don't know, changing the
game, man. Like I saw so many, so many awesome videos of
little kids trying it or, I guess, whether it
was college kids or whatnot.
So I mean, to me personally, I took
a lot of pride in I guess maybe trying to inspire
somebody to pick up a hockey stick.
But I guess if you wanted to take it as it was bad for
the game, I guess that's just his opinion.
- Yeah, I can really respect that answer. I don't think
Torts meant any, you know, ill intent by that.
- Yeah
- He's just old school, you know, dump the puck low,
- Totally
shoot low for rebounds. That's that's the kind of guy he is but
- Yeah
- I could say personally, I walked into my rink for a
beer league game this week. No joke.
I saw the guys flipping the puck over the net going for
your play, so you inspire the youth around the country,
man. I appreciate everything you're doin', changing the
game of hockey and we appreciate you hopping on this interview.
- Thanks, Nasher. I picked up some stuff watching you on
YouTube, bro.
- No, you did not.
- I saw your, I saw your roller hockey highlights, bro.
That's where my, where some of the between the legs comes from
- You've got to be kidding me. I posted that and I
thought I was just kind of making a joke, I didn't know
you actually watched the video.
- Yeah, of course, man.
- Dude I appreciate the love. Thank you so much and best
of luck going forward this year, man.
Thanks, man. Appreciate it.